i think all right what do we need i
think we're good
i think we're good the spider-man
news that wasn't directly spider-man
news
that was the casting of aaron
taylor johnson of
uh craven yeah right
which is so interesting to me because
he's in the mcu or was because he's dead
um
so i don't know
either way um i do believe
spider-man is going to be in craven i
don't think it's going to be the other
way around
for everybody asking uh it's too late
unless this is really late news for us
so that's the big thing right
unless this is really really late news
and aaron taylor johnson has been
craving and is magically in spider-man
knowing home
it's it's he's not going to be
rise kirkwood thanks for super chat
what's new with spider-man any news at
all yes
that's what we're tackling right now um
pals thanks for the super chat hey
warren since we've gotten new suits for
maybe all spider-man movies
you think we'll get a new suit for no
way home if so which one
um uh i
do yes that is my official answer
i do uh i'm not sure which one because
so the biggest thing about like for
no way home and far from home was that
you know like tony stark wasn't there
but he's still like happy was there and
he still created the new suit
uh you know pepper and happy are still
there and they're gonna still be there
in spider-man no way home you know it's
not like they're
disappearing and yes
it might be kind of hard for people
for for spider-man to see people like
his friends and stuff like that
but at the same time like you you know
happy's gonna help him like
you know pepper would help him if he if
he showed up you know what i mean like
they're still gonna be there so he's
still gonna have access to
iron man tech now here's what i think
might
happen i think that
due to the multiverse and everything
kind of going crazy
uh the whole identity thing might not
matter
like oh that could reset in seconds too
much well too much chaos to care
about hey who's spider-man because at
that point in time it'd be like
spider-man save us
and then you know it would actually be
pretty cool
if everybody knew who's that you know
peter parker was spider-man
because people know who's iron man is
right they know he's tony stark
i know who everybody steve rogers is
captain america
you know why not take it down that path
to where everybody's just
gonna know that peter parker is
spider-man
i mean to me i think that would be
pretty cool um
oh different way of doing it and it
looks like spider-man's here to stay for
a while so there
for a while yeah definitely gonna be
trying to put again their own stamp on
it from the other movies even if they're
bringing the other movies in here it's
gotta separate it's got to be its own
thing so that would be a really cool way
of changing it up
yeah i really would um heyd thanks for
that super chat
um i wish i knew that currency to know
if that was like a really big super chat
cause it looks
looks like it is but even if it's not
thank you
and if it is thank you there's a rumor
floating around that spider-man will
become
man spider he told me require spider-man
head off is that true
i've never heard that but i'm gonna say
it's not true
i'm gonna i'm gonna go ahead and say
that's not true so but yeah so
we're getting a preview for no way home
tomorrow i think right it's thursday
yeah
yeah i never know what that is anymore
yeah and the preview isn't
gonna be a trailer for all those asking
um i stated that in my video
yesterday yeah yesterday
it's not gonna it's not gonna be a
trailer but i do believe the trailer is
coming soon we're gonna get to that but
tomorrow
it's coming in total film magazine um if
you caught my video
yesterday you'll know this but there
there's a
picture of loki in the cover and it says
marvel preview at the very top
and then it lists a bunch of different
movies and spider-man is one of those
movies now
as far as what to expect from this which
is what i want to talk about because i
want to kind of like set
expectations i wouldn't expect much
excuse me and this is what i said in
my video yesterday i i wouldn't expect
much
um i would expect a little bit about
the plot um synopsis almost
a synopsis of some sort maybe a little
bit more in-depth synopsis
um than anything that we've gotten
really so far
but i think we are going to find out a
little bit more about the movie i would
not expect
anything relating to the spider-verse
multiverse
i just don't think that's gonna happen
i know we want it but they're not going
to reveal
something so big in a magazine
in a magazine yeah so like let's set the
expectations right now nothing huge is
going to come from this now they say
it's a preview
what does that mean um
tell us more of what we already know tom
holland's back and his adventures are
getting crazier than ever
i really hope it's more than that
[Laughter]
i really hope it's more than that i mean
if you're marvel
and sony and you know the world is
all eyes on you you know as far as
cinematic epicness and anticipation goes
all eyes are on you you've already told
everybody on the cover of this magazine
there's a spider-man sneak peek
right what are you trying to relate to
your fans
through this magazine right and total
film has partnered with disney and
marvel
um for i mean turtle film's about as big
as it gets for magazines right
yeah i mean they're they're big right
but i mean ew is probably bigger
entertainment winkley but
total film is huge and they've done it
for avengers infinity war avengers
in-game
you know they've done a lot um i think
maybe they might mention something about
the villains
this could be something that's coming
because
everything's like out of the bag already
about alfred molina and jimmy fox i mean
both actors have admitted there in the
movie already so it's like
why bother hiding it there's just no
point
so maybe they say something about
oh you know spider-man's gonna have to
tackle villains that
he himself hasn't come in contact with
before but other spider-man have
like that would be cool that would
allude to the spider-verse
but it wouldn't give it all away i'm
telling you guys right now i don't
expect anything
for toby or or andrew like that's that's
just not going to happen that's
that's not what it's going to be
unfortunately you know um
it's not it's not reveal it's not going
to be revealed
in a magazine now
that's just the expectations i want to
set don't don't expect anything huge and
then if we get something huge in the
magazine
the so-called preview that they're
calling it then awesome right
then sweet but don't expect it um
so here's here's kind of
where i think the trailer might just
kind of come out um we
could be getting it let's take a look at
my calendar here
so here's here's the big deal next
uh tuesday wednesday
i don't remember the exact date when it
what is the exact date for tom holland's
birthday
is it the second um
it's the first it's the first it's the
first so so a lot of people are thinking
that we could be getting it on the first
because the chongqi trailer came out on
sima liu's birthday
but don't don't let don't let this
be the like what's the word just don't
let this be
you know the example moving forward
because that's not
you know gonna be how it is right uh
they're not just gonna be like okay all
the movies you have coming up let's just
release the trailers on people's
birthdays and stuff like that however
kevin feige's birthday
is uh the second so um
that would be pretty cool
if it's like oh for you know kevin feige
the president
of marvel city's birthday and tom
holland's birthday we're gonna
throw a little teaser trailer out there
right uh
i think that would be pretty cool and
it's about
time so it could
happen on the birthdays now i would say
that's as soon as it's gonna happen
i'm not i'm not expecting anything to
happen tomorrow at all
um i'm expecting to learn more about the
movie from total film magazine
um and and maybe some pictures and those
pictures aren't gonna be anything
spectacular
like um andrew garfield tomorrow today
somebody's saying there were no pictures
yeah i mean i retweeted that too but
well you never really know
random accounts on twitter who knows
right
oh sorry guys there's not gonna be a
picture what do you know right
who are you right exactly you know like
if it came from somebody
that i trusted you know yeah right from
total total
[Laughter]
i'm complete film
total film is my son um
maybe uh if they did do a photo i would
expect it like peter parker with doctor
strange
yeah that's just what i expect i won't
expect anything huge maybe even wanda so
but here's where you have to kind of
take a look at everything so
uh shanxi is in
september i don't believe
yeah release
september 3rd is the exact day then you
have
the eternals which is coming out in
november so
the trailers for shanxi and the
internals came out a month apart
and their release dates are a month
apart
spider-man no way home is a month from
the eternals
it would be safe to assume that the
trailers would be
a month apart which means
we have three weeks
right essentially almost the middle of
june
okay that that's just movie math
um normal that's just moving math so for
those asking like when to expect it
that's when i would expect it if it
comes out before awesome
super cool um and i hope they do it
on freaking tom holland or kevin feige's
birthday
right oh but wait a second
i mean we got a little tiny
earlier so would they
here's okay so here i just thought of
something they just saw something
would they release the spider-man
no way home trailer the week before loki
comes out
because i have the press conference
for loki and i believe let me check
look at my email and figure out when
that is so the press conference
for loki is june
7th okay so it's a
couple days before i mean really the day
before for us because we're gonna do the
live stream on tuesday night
so maybe maybe that week maybe that week
could be it because if not
it's definitely going to be probably
after loki
unfortunately so that's great i would
i would understand if they postponed it
a little bit from the normal movie math
that you came up with and wait till
towards the end of loki
so that's what i'm saying let's hype up
a little bit more how many episodes
loki six six episodes they actually
haven't officially announced it yet but
are they not everyone's well somebody
said that kevin foggy said it way back
like a couple years ago which you can't
hold him to that couple years ago
right so to six yeah so yeah so
maybe tom holland's birthday would get a
tiny the tiniest teaser
like 20 seconds long i could i could
i could see tom holland doing something
on like instagram
yeah like a tiny little teaser that
literally gives us nothing yeah i
i could i could see him teasing
something on instagram right like maybe
doctor strange finding him and being
like
what have you done boy and then like
that
[Laughter]
because we have that one picture of um
zendaya and jacob with uh him and
they're all like looking at somebody and
it clearly looks like doctor strange and
it actually looks like they're in the
sanctum
so maybe we get that little clip where
it's like
what are you doing here what have you
done like you said like that you know
it's like and then that's the end of it
we hear nothing else until
the last week or the week after loki
ends yeah
now that's some movie calculus so roland
james says
morbius than a motherbig carnage far
from home trailers all came out on a
monday
well monday's memorial day
so the first
uh yeah so i'm not
sure oh red ninja says toby's birthday
is june 27th look at that
that would be cool but i don't think
they're going to i don't think they're
going to reveal
toby and andrew in the tv
i think they might almost surprise that
they do it the full trailer
i think if they want to bring people to
see the movie they'll do it in the full
trailer
but like the tiniest little teasers
no like just show them like for like a
split second like like two
seconds like like two seconds
and so now
i'm just not sure if marvel would well i
guess marvel promoted the falcon in the
winter soldier
they actually did they released a full
falcon in the winter soldier
uh trailer during the middle of one
division now granted it was the super
bowl
and they had to take advantage of that
right you have to take advantage of the
super
super bowl but it's not it's not against
marvel to
to announce something in the middle of
loki and that would actually probably
push people towards loki
so it could come in in the middle blokey
so
i'm hoping that's what it is but now so
the next
you know kind of topic
sony cast aaron taylor johnson
as craven which is like out of left
field completely
right um i'm talking about craven
anymore everybody moved on
uh yeah corey westerhold thanks for the
super chat yeah the press conference is
monday
um right before loki the 7th
excuse me which i'll be attending but
uh i think we're talking about the first
here
yeah the for the first because that's
tom holland's birthday
so that's why we're thinking well the
31st is monday actually the 31st is
monday
so maybe a tuesday i don't know i i like
the whole
it's always been like a monday thing
like i like that that thought
um but i think i'd be more satisfied if
it was uh
if it was on tom holland's birthday i
just feel like i'd be more satisfied
he deserved it he's he's kept his mouth
shut
and hasn't spoiled anything and uh
uh halls182 thanks for that super chat
show them showed them in the full
trailer for a few seconds at the end
then with them all websing it together
we're here to help you peter along the
lines
yeah i think that would be super super
cool now here's what i'm
i i've said before i don't know if it's
in a video or i just said it to like
friends or something like that or yeah i
have no idea
um here's what i think would
um be kind of cool is
i just completely lost my chain of
thought
um i think if they did it like
end game so and spoiler alert if you
haven't seen in game which like if you
don't watch it right now like if you
haven't
uh but spoiler for anyone who hasn't
seen ingame if they did it like in game
like one of the big parts was captain
america wielding mjolnir
right saying avengers assemble blah blah
blah blah
and they didn't show that in the
original trailer obviously but once the
movie came out like a week into it they
showed it
in like tv spots and stuff so
they might wait like a week for like the
die hard fans
to go see the movie and experience the
spider verse
because like the first day once somebody
sees it
everyone's gonna reveal what's in it
right
everyone's gonna say it the spider
versus spider versus spider versus
spider verse blah blah blah blah
and it's just going to get out right
it's going to be all over twitter it's
going to be a little over instagram
there's going to be leaked photos people
are going to be snapping photos
in the picture in the in the theaters
all that i mean
it's you're not going to be a secret
very long past the first day you're
never gonna you're never gonna be able
to keep it a secret
robert coat thanks for that five dollar
uh super chat nba finals come in yeah
that's a perfect time as well
as you know if you want a ton of people
to see it that's a perfect time you know
and marvel has a tendency to do things
like that actually marvel just recently
did that team up thing
with the nba when the nba players took
on like different heroes and stuff like
like
the personas of different heroes and
stuff like that so
yeah i mean that's very very i just
realized that we're like kind of off the
screen here
let's move up a little bit because that
looks kind of weird
oh we're like low down yeah okay
um but i think so really like the first
day
the movie's out it's just blown up right
so
honestly at that point in time
you might as well put something of it in
the trailers
right because it's almost like what's
the point
like you don't have to put it in the
teaser trailer and you don't even have
to put it in the first trailer that
comes out
but eventually you're gonna put it in a
trailer because everybody's just going
to know you know
this is going to be
probably one of the biggest movies ever
i mean if this is everything that we've
surmised it to be this will rival end
game
for sure i agree with generations
several generations of fans with
arguably one of the most popular
marvel characters across the board video
games comic books
everything probably isn't going to be a
groundbreaking cinematic event if it is
what it is becoming which explains you
know the secrecy the latency of
releasing a trailer
trying to make sure every single dot and
i everything's crossed everything makes
sense
so a hundred percent that hype is going
to be there
and it's going to be very meticulous the
way they do reveal that
which is why it's not going to be a
total film magazine
no no you know it's just not
no so tomorrow
narrow visuals thanks to that super chat
miles morales at in credit scene of the
movie
i think that'll be fantastic especially
you know spider-verse and everything
you don't want to overwhelm the movie
because it
it's already seen me like it's pretty
overwhelming so you don't really want to
like
yeah you don't like oops i dropped that
you don't want to overwhelm the movie
that much
but um for a post-credit scene
or even like a small scene in the movie
where you meet miles
and he's not yet maybe spider-man or
something like that like that would be
pretty cool
like i think that would be really really
cool um they did that with
tom holland spider-man correct me if i'm
wrong but didn't they confirm
at some point iron man saved him in one
of the iron man movies
yeah but that was like that that was an
iron man 2
the little kid wearing an iron man mask
they said that that was peter parker but
like i think they admitted
like at the time like that wasn't
what they were thinking of in the moment
they just went back and said yeah it's
him
it's like but it wasn't when they filmed
them right you know because they
couldn't even at that time because they
didn't have the rights of spider-man
and even when uh civil war was coming
out
and people are like yeah spider-man's
gonna be in civil war everyone's like no
impossible can't do that because of the
deal with sony
and then it's like well guess what you
can make a deal about anything right
yeah and money talks so and that's my
big question
and that is there's probably a very
small handful of people who actually
know
the the everything going on behind the
new sony
disney deal right because there is some
type of new deal on the table
and that's where i come in with a
question with aaron taylor johnson is
is this part of the deal with disney or
is sony trying to put pressure on disney
to get them into the mcu a little bit
more
well this is why spider-man's on the
wall and that's why
right quote-unquote adrian toomes is in
this trailer and the daily bugle is this
all pressure that sony's trying to put
on disney
or is there some type of secret deal
that we haven't actually no it's a
secret deal
it's a secret deal marvel um
if i'm disney and marvel there's no way
i'm making a new deal and going yeah you
guys can do whatever you want with other
spider-man characters
but we're controlling this like there's
no way
there's no way everything has to be like
in sync with each other
and here here's what i think
and i'm gonna do a video on this soon um
i think
that this is gonna be like this spider
verse
is going to be so much bigger than we
think it is i think it's going to go
into sony's universe the sp umc
and i hate it every time i say that
they gotta come up with something
different yeah something way better
the sony pictures universe of
marvel yeah smc you're right um but i i
i think it's going to be huge and you
know there's talks about a fourth toby
maguire movie that we never got that
could happen now
there's talks that andrew andrew mcguire
andrew garfield's going to stay into is
going to stay in the mcu
uh or the sony spider-man version after
that
and of top of andrew garfield jeez
toby maguire staying in the mcu yeah
toby i would love toby
i think andrew would do a pretty good
job too with feige at the helm
uh because i didn't enjoy the but
amazing spider-man movies i just
i just i just didn't here's something
the last couple days
i've been wondering what is the
possibility
oh that was a good word possibility that
they got
toby and not andrew they only needed one
they didn't get all of them
uh it's a possibility but i think if i'm
andrew
and kevin feige is coming up to me and
all the sony executives are like
we got toby you know we want to bring
you into
like think about how big this is going
to freaking be what if they didn't even
want them though they're like yeah we
actually only need toby
uh i don't think so i i don't think
that's
no i think they realize that
people there there are a lot of people
that like andrew
garfield as spider-man there are
oh absolutely and there are people who
enjoy those movies
and yes chat andrew mcguire yes yeah we
missed
just just no it's andrew mcguire that's
how i'm referring to both of them from
now on
is andrew mugwire it'll save us time
so andrew mcguire is both of them both
of them combined
uh andrew bullham choir
[Laughter]
um what i don't remember we're talking
about now because they had
andrew and toby maybe only one of them
coming over
i don't remember specifically where
you're going the only one is coming
andrew mcguire
andrew mcguire's coming that's it
everybody andrew mcguire in the chat on
my next video that i post andrew mcguire
we're gonna start this i'll tweet it
right now i mean what would an andrew
mcguire even look like
uh he definitely has spiderman 3 toby
mcguire's hair
hashtag andrew mcguire
on twitter if you know you know if you
know you know
if you're in my live stream cosmic bros
i think my twitter handle is
cosmic warren13 andrew mcguire if you
know you know and there it is
what is my twitter handle cosmic warren
13.
go to my twitter and retweet
retweet andrew mcguire there we go
and there oh wait okay we got fro
she toby garfield andrew mcguire and
toby garfield there we go
um i don't i don't think
sony and marvel disney would only go
after toby
i just it would be such
a waste to only go after one of them
that's true but then you and you talked
about this already this movie is
just it's a mess that's like the best
way to call it right now with the amount
of people
villains good guys characters that are
exist in the mcu characters that exist
in different universes it's gonna be
a chore to get them all screen time
unless this movie's two and a half three
hours long so yeah it'll be
yeah it's gonna be cool which it might
be i i would
i'm thinking two and a half hours uh
hold on hudson
can you pay so sorry if i didn't
pronounce that right cosmic wolf pack
kicks arse y'all keep up the good work
day thank you so much we appreciate that
cosmic wolf pack i like um
well for so i mean we'll talk about this
after let's talk about
i think we're going with cosmic bros but
i think i call
i i when i first started like you know
when i was six months into it i i called
like thousands subscribers the wolf pack
wolfgang sometime yeah i said what up
wolfgang i think is what i said
yeah but i think i stopped because i
wanted it to be more original but i
don't know
that's what we are we're a wolf pack a
wolf gang what was the actual quote here
wolf pack i think the wolf pack sounds
sounds cooler what do you guys think
wolf pack is that what we want to call
ourselves
wolf pack i don't know we're all just
nerds hanging out
we're just nerds hanging out cosmic
andrew mcguire
yes thanks zach davis cosmic andrew
mcguire
that's those are the characters in the
movie cosmic andrew mcguire
and uh but i did say andrew mcguire
that's that's what i
yeah uh narrow visuals again thanks for
super chat this movie has to have toby
in it
uh because why would electro and octo
come back
plus movie connects multiverse madness
and water yeah no i i
alright so without saying any names
whatsoever and this is not coming from
disney i have talked to people
who have said yeah it's a spider-verse
film
and i trust them
and i haven't seen photos of
toby mogar or andrew garfield but i've
seen other photos
so i'm like 99.9 percent
confident that it's well it 100 is a
spider-verse film because of the other
characters
but just because it's a spider-verse
film doesn't mean toby and andrew are in
it and like i said i haven't seen
photo photos are bright i haven't seen
photos well let's flip this around then
so what happens to marvel
to the fan base to phase four the
remainder of phase four and phase five
if this doesn't end up being a
multiverse film if this is another ralph
boner
you know oh here's electro and doc but
it doesn't actually mean anything
um you know it's it's kind of good
that's a good question it's a curious
question because to me
if i am
if i am sony
and marvel and disney and i
didn't plan on having a spider verse
i would alter my plans and have a tiny
spider verse
there's got to be exact at this point
right such a huge wave of overwhelming
fans
they know they know um
oh yeah they know they know what we're
all talking about
and if i'm them
and my plan wasn't to have these people
in the movie i would make it to where i
could get them in for a brief cameo
even if it's for like a minute where
strange opens a portal and he sees
toby and then he's like oh wrong
universe you're not spider-man in that
universe right and then he shuts it up
and then opens another one and there's
andrew and it's like oops sorry that's
another one too you're not
spider-man in that one either well i
guess i guess he is because he's peter
parker but he looks different but
anyways
if if i'm sony and marvel in them
i'm making it be that way even if that
was not my original plan because you
know people are
gonna kind of be pissed off
well i mean for me and and and we call
it the ralph boner effect because
i mean what a perfect name for this
coincidence but as a fan
as somebody watched one division was
super hyped up by the way they built it
to this huge crescendo
i was just disappointed that it was
ralph i didn't think it was haha
funny marvel pulled a fast one i think a
lot of people were disappointed
this wasn't a good joke you brought in
quicksilver from the fox universe that
you just acquired
with all of this multiverse rumors going
around doctor strange juan division
doctor stranger the multiverse of
madness
and there's just some random dude that
happens to look the same named ralph
bono
well you know the writer came out
i i think it was the writer jack shafer
um
that came out and they said like that's
not
necessarily done like that'll kind of
unfold a little bit more
so maybe they're saving it for the
multiverse right i mean
okay i don't know i mean i did
on cosmic culture and here's a shameless
plug today
a video talking about deadpool 3 is
going to be deadpool trying to take over
the multiverse for fun
and that comes from i'd watch that it's
patreon
i'd watch that for sure but there you go
again here we are more
rumors and trickles of the multiverse
well the multiverse is the future
coming over like when are we gonna
actually get the steak and potatoes of
the multiverse
in marvel i think loki so you think loki
you know three weeks from now two weeks
from now
we're starting to get some of that
multiverse
this is why we bought fox this is what
we've got this is where we're headed
uh no i don't think we're gonna see
different people like that but i think
that's gonna set the presidents of like
hey here's the multiverse it's screwed
up and blah blah blah well i mean it is
because we are going to see different
loki's right
mm-hmm but we're not going to see x-men
from the fox universe you know
stuff like that you know we may never
actually see x-men from the fox universe
they brought the characters
yeah that doesn't mean they have to use
i feel like they could easily get some
of the characters back
oh for sure but that doesn't mean that
they want to maybe they just want to
rewrite that completely
deadpool mcguire there you go wade
mcguire
huh i said wade mcguire
wade maguire there we go i'm excited for
deadpool but
i i think sony is
planning something really big and it
could be that
they're going to have other movies with
toby in it after knowing home and other
movies with andrew in it after no way
home
which i think would be insanely cool and
there's talks about that and there's
been reports and rumors about that um
obviously we won't know until after
no way home but but yeah but the casting
of aaron
taylor johnson as craven is very
interesting um again unless this is a
really really
late report i don't think that he's
going to be in no way home
but i do believe uh tom holland
there's too many toms hardy hiddleston
tom holland is going to be in the craven
film um
because they're not like gonna kill oh
you think tom holland jumps over the
sony verse
for that film i think that's the big i
think that's the main deal
that sony and marvel and disney made i
think
that's the deal is spider-man can jump
between
the mcu and the sp umc and i mean that's
a quote from kevin feige you know that
right he he said he is the only
character who can jump between different
universes
and maybe he was just talking about no
way home
going to different right maybe they knew
that far ahead
that toby maguire and them were going to
be in this you know
uh yeah
that is the next big question then
if we're expecting which i don't
disagree with you to see tom holland
make his way over to the
smcu um do we get
a tiny little cameo of tom holland
either in an
end credit post credit scene in venom
trying to set that up
is that still completely off the table
because we know sony's been fighting for
that
i think that was probably included in
the in the deal
um i mean we have to get a venom in
spider-man film yeah yeah i mean sony
wanted
not necessarily spider-man but they
wanted peter
to be in the first venom
so with whatever new deal that they got
that comes that comes with it um
especially with craven coming and i
don't think he's going to be in morbius
but it seems you know vulture is so it
seems very clear
that they have something really big plan
and i think with the casting of craven
um i think that's the next step to this
huge
plan that sony has uh
and i think it's part of marvel studios
as well
i think i think there's really
really really big plans
oh there's something for spiderman
there's something huge coming
yeah and i also feel like that's a
matthew
rivera that's a good point you know i
feel like if all the stuff about
the spider verse and everything wasn't
true
if i'm kevin feige i'd probably come out
and say
guys seriously this isn't it
right you know and i would believe that
if kevin if kevin feige came out and
said it
i would believe it and i'm kind of upset
because um
kevin feige is not available for
personal interviews for loki
i just found out um as i was talking to
disney
about the press conference and you know
doing interviews with the director and
writers and stuff like that
unfortunately tom hiddleston and owen
wilson and kevin feige aren't available
for one-on-one interviews
which sucks because i was going to ask
about how
loki you know kind of ties into
spider-man
no way home because the last time
somebody asked kevin feige about that he
didn't comment on it
um which to me is always yes it does
connect
like if it's a no it's no but also at
the same time like don't give it all
away or
something um
just stares on stairs
the press conference where you can still
we're going to be able to ask uh
everybody i say loki tom huddleston
questions
uh owen wilson and kevin feige so
hopefully i get asked a question i did
get to ask one last time
um but there's a lot of media outlets in
there trying to ask questions and some
people don't get to ask some
uh so hopefully i get to ask one and
hopefully um
it's a i can come up with a good one uh
and of course i'll you know break down
everything that happened in the press
conference so immediately after because
it's coming out
monday and the next day is
at night time is the the live stream
that
we're gonna be doing so a lot of stuff
coming too close yeah
and we're moving yeah we are moving
monday too
so that's going to be fun just marvel
please don't release it monday do it
tuesday release the trailer and tom
holland's birthday like
please please please please please
please uh rachel knight online
imagine if sonny marvel swerved us all
and instead of andrew garfield and tommy
we get two jackman and wesley snipes oh
my gosh
that'll be hilarious right freaking the
old blade
hugh jackman i i hope we see hugh
jackman at some point in time
uh as a different i don't see how we
don't
alternate version even if it's just him
and not wolverine like just
him as like a funny bystander or
something like that
so um so yeah but anyways
the main topic of today was the fact
that the preview tomorrow
i wanted to set expectations it's
looking like it's not going to be
insanely huge we're just gonna find out
a little bit more about the plot don't
expect
any any huge reveals don't expect
a picture of toby mcguire and andrew
garfield with tom holland
sadly i don't think that's gonna happen
but in trailer update
um it could happen on tom holland's
birthday which is the first which is
tuesday
um maybe kevin feige's birthday which is
the third
again i would not expect this but if it
happens well i'll be super excited about
obviously but if you go by movie math
and you go by with what marvel's done in
the past
it should happen in three weeks
so like right in the middle of loki
pretty much right which
would work or the nba finals like some
people have said which i
which i think would be a pretty good
idea because if you want people to see
it that's how you do it
um and then aaron taylor johnson is cast
as craven
i think this is big
thank you noah noel blake appreciate
that
um i think this is big i think
the casting of craven is going to be
really really really big i think the
spider verse is about to be something
really big
i think they're the plans for it are a
lot bigger
than we realize at this point in time
especially with people stating that
andrew
garfield andrew mcguire andrew garfield
and toby mcguire uh could be sticking
around
after and that's like a big thing to me
is like andrew garfield
and toby mcguire could be sticking
around for further projects
after no way home so i think
i think we're all about to be very
pleasantly surprised with
what they haven't planned for us or in
store for us
so and again like i said i've talked to
people
who usually are right
and do have like people on the inside
and they've said yes it is a
spider-verse film i obviously won't say
who
but um they've said yes they've said
it's a spider-verse film so
um i think we're not ready i think we're
not ready for it but
we'll see we'll see but that's that's
pretty much the news for today
um it's cool
that they got aaron taylor johnson but
it's also
weird because he was like in the mcu
but you know he's gone and now he's in
the sp umc
which might also be able to get into the
mcu which is
weird we
we definitely need some answers maybe
we'll get a tiny bit of answers
tomorrow um
maybe so tomorrow i will be covering
whatever is said in total film magazine
whatever the article on spiderman is
i'll definitely make sure to cover
and talk about um and hopefully we get
something right promotions obviously are
kicking in with the film now and people
are starting to
you know talk more about it and the
trailer's right around the corner
and hopefully something something comes
out tomorrow
so but that's it for today guys just
wanted to go
do the show again because i know a lot
of people have been asking about it so
instead of doing a video today i was
excited just to do the show
say hi to everybody appreciate everybody
stopping by
appreciate the super chats for all those
did appreciate everyone who commented
and appreciate everyone who
just sitting there in the background
watching let's go ahead and stop uh
any super chat that might come in now
because there's a little bit of delay i
don't wanna uh
i don't wanna miss any super chat so
um so let's see it's spider-man film
uh i don't know what the correct term
is for that spider-man film
men spider-man spider-man's i asked this
before
i think it's spider-man's i actually
think it is spider-man
because that's spider-man as a title
it's a title so it would be spider-man's
it would be spider-man
it would be a spider-man's film film
grammatically on that note before i make
full of myself
i'm gonna end it and look out for my
video tomorrow and whatever the heck
we're gonna find out
about spider-man no way home uh whatever
total film says
that's what i have for you so
everybody's chris over cosmic culture
that way go get it go get a stormbreaker
be sure to subscribe
we're giving away stormbreaker right
here uh
a new one not that one that one's mine
can't have it that's my hard work
my hard work not yours but uh yeah at
the 31st monday we are picking a winner
so be sure to subscribe to cosmic
culture
and uh love you all thanks for stopping
by